sympa les chéris on va passer maintenant
une vidéo diffusée sur les réseaux
sociaux alors c'est un autre
complètement un autre domaine cette
vidéo montre un groupe de personnes de
confession juive j'adore ça un group de
conf en train de prier en public alors
c'est maintenant à l'aéroport d'Orly
alors il y avait on avait eu la prière
musulmane cette semaine et la scène se
serait déroulée à l'aéroport d'Orly en
dehors des zones de culte dédié même
question êtes-vous choqué alors il va
faire c'est pas êtes-vous choqué qu'
faut dire regardez c'est parti
alors euh êtes-vous choqué euh Gil
Verdes toujours non toujours non c'est
tout a et c'est tout aussi formidable
que les musulmans qui prient à roissi ça
ne me gêne nullement c'est bien ces gens
sont heureux ils sont entre eux ils ne
dérangent personne je ne suis absolument
pas choqué même si la lo leur impose
d'aller dans les zones dédiées voilà
parce qu'il y en a comme à mais c'est
pas grave cy c'est bien de prier ça ne
me dérange pas du tout alors Daniel mais
c'est le même si moi ça me dérangeait
pour les musulmans ça me dérange pour
pour les Juifs après est-ce que il y
aura pas là je là je les crois sans
doute sincère mais est-ce qu'il y aura
pas de la provocation après on n sait
rien parce que si on commence à à dire
que ça ça va ça passe ça non non moi
ça il y a des lieux dédiés à à 100 m ils
le font là ça peut êre de la provocation
excuse-moi on a été trop angélique on en
arrive à des donc je pense qu'il faut
arrêter maintenant il y a une loi il y a
des lieux c'est très très bien et
évidemment que j'adore quand les gens
prient mais voilà il y a des lieux pour
ça donc moi j'ai peur qu'on aille dans
la provocation on laisse tout passer on
fera Raymond après et moi je pense
exactement comme Raymond et on a été
interpellé tous les deux hier je crois
sur les réseaux en gros ouais vous dites
ça mais si vous aviez vu cette image
vous n'auriez pas dit la même chose donc
évidemment ce qui était prévu est arrivé
on nous a traité de islamophobe donc
donc maintenant de la même manière je
n'aime pas ça ne me choque pas je ne
suis pas pour je ne veux pas qu'on
montre quand on prie je trouve que la la
la pratique de la religion ça doit être
quelque chose d'intime de privé donc des
espaces dédiés qui sont ouverts et c'est
formidable et j'adore ça mais moi je ne
veux pas qu'on qu'on me montre dans un
terminal d'aéroport dans la rue
n'importe où voilà ça ça reste privé et
je ne suis pas pour voilà et donc dans
ce cas-là aussi je suis contre Jean euh
non moi je suis pas choqué parce queon
peut pas dire qu'il y a pas de trouble à
l'ordre publicque alors on peut se
raccrocher à la loi mais je trve il son
comme ça choque pas h
question
d' ou pas d'accord c'est vot question
pour vous êtes des malins vous êtes des
malins parce que le jour
o aura 3 juif qui vont prier et qu'on
dira l'avion il part pas maintenant
parce qu'on attend les 300 personnes qui
finissent de prier c'est une connerie ce
que je raconte et que tu loupes tes
correspond et
C hier pareil éta dans et si se passait
ça et si se passait ça c'est pas la
question qu'on nous pose on nous pose
est-ce que hier vous étiez choqué sur
les les les pèlerins qui partaient à la
Mecque et qui parce que le le les salles
de de de de prière écuméniqu étaient
trop loin était étaiit ils ils ont fait
là ils ont pas troublé l'ordre public là
c'est la même question dans les deux cas
moi ça ne me gêne pas parce que là pour
l'instant on estond à cette photo
précisément je dis pas en général
évidemment que j'aurais préféré que les
uns et les autres aillent se se
recueillir dans les salles de prière
dédiées mais visiblement il y avait un
c'était trop loin ou c'était pas dans
les bons terminaux ça ne me pose pas de
problème quand il y a pas deour à
l'ordre public clair Clement sur cette
vidéo et sur les pèlerins musulmans hier
il y avit pas de trouble à l'ordre publ
mais il pourra pas y avoir des lieux
dédiés dans tous les tous les terminau
d' dans tout les madame madame s'il vous
plaît mais moi je trouve ça beau les
prières je VO même pas ce qu'il de ce ce
qu' a de dérangeant dans cette image moi
ça me déranger pas qu'il a 300 musulmans
300 juifs qui pr qu'est-ce qu'il y a de
on est en train
pourquoi de voir quelqu'un prier on est
en de par de ça comme cétait quelque
chose
de a beaucoup plus d' que de gens qui on
mais et alors mais c'est pas parce qu'on
est c'est ça c'est ça mais c'est ça le
vivre ensemble en quoi c'est une
agression de de de voir d'IST prière je
suis désolé et et Dan quand tu as fait
un raccourci en disant déjà qu'on on a
accepté beaucoup de choses pour arriver
aux dérives dans lesquelles nous sommes
pardon ça n'a rien à voir une prière
c'est beau les dérives extrémistes de
certaines religions parfois oui c'est
mal mais ça n'a rien à voir en
l'occurrence et le vivre ensemble c'est
trouver beau de voir un musulman prier
un juif priant catholique prier je
trouve ça très beau moi dans les syages
dans les églises dans les temp pourquoi
pas ailleurs c'est comme ça c'est
l'instrumentalisation des photos enfin
de ses vidéos hier elles étent
instrumentalisé aujourd'hui elles sont
encore instrumentalisées le pays est
suffisamment fracturé pour pas utiliser
ces photos pour essayer de monter les
uns contre les autres pas hasard
mainant hier comme
aujourd'hui en quoi nous on
instrumentalise plus que vous en fait en
disant ça parle r générale parce que
vous vous avez hyper gentil hyper humain
hyper ouvert hyper tolérant et en fait
c'est c'est vous nous rendez nous hyper
raciste hyper islamophobe qu' hyper
antism
êtes choqué oui je suis choqué parce que
on prie chez soi tout simplement en fait
il y a rien d'autre à dire on prie chez
soi dans un lieu de culte dans une cul
mais pas dans un lie publicah oui en ils
ont pas le choix il prennentavion des
prières régulières à certaines
heur c'est comme la dernière fois je
pense que ce qu'on disait avec Mar c'est
que l'avion était en retard et que voilà
et que ils on av pas temps rendre dans
dans la salle de prère
là aussi il devit prier bon vous oui oui
mais c'est toujours pare cette photo là
elle est pas choquante moi je trouve
qu'il y a rien de plus beau que des gens
qui prient donc ça m'embête de mettre
oui je suis choqué il faut juste voir
plus plus loin que ça je suis
désolé alors si ça ça nous choque pas 5
si en a 1000 pourquoi ça nous choquerait
pourquoi pourquoi on en voudrait à 1000
personnes et pourquoi pas ch je le r enc
c'est pas chocant est-ce qu'on est
d'accord ou est-ce qu'on est pas
d'accord que tout le monde s'amuse à
prier partout dans les li' à tu
comprends mon la sémantique des mots jou
pas sur ma non culture jouez pas
là-dessus je prends les mots comme ils
sortent joueis pas là-dessus vous ai dit
l'autre fois que ce soit catholique juif
ou musulman je suis pas choqué je suis
pas d'accord on est venu m'interpeller
sur les réseaux sociaux en montrant ça
qu'est-ce que tu en penses qu'est-ce que
tu en passes alors je vous le dis je le
dis que ce soit un juif qui prie comme
ça que ce soit un musulman un catholique
je ne suis pas d'accord je suis pas
choqué s'ils veulent prier 20 personnes
ça me dérange pas mais je ne suis pas
d'accord et je suis très content que ça
passe ça et je suis très content qu'on
passe passe là parce que les gens disent
ouais c'est que des musulmans ça aurait
été des Juifs vous l'aurez pas passé
tiens votre réponse elle est là on passe
quand même que ce soit juif musulman on
passe quand même voilà et moi je reste
sur ma je reste sur ma ligne je suis pas
en train de faire du de l'eau tiède oui
parce que je veux pas qu'on m'insulte
dehors alors je vais dire oui bah c'est
c'est facile à dire non ça me choque pas
c'est facile à dire là à la télé je suis
pas choqué ils ont le droit c'est des
religions de paix et d'amour ils ont le
droit de faire la prière ça ne me
dérange
pas
trouve r tu as le droit d'avoir ta
position en revanche ne ni pas la nôtre
en disant que si on a cette position là
c'est parce que soitdisant nous
n'aurions pas de coroness pardon c'est
extrêmement désagréable pour nous on a
le droit d'avoir une position elle n'est
pas conforme à la tienne mais ne nous
dit pas que parce l' par parce qu'on pas
on on n pas on est ce ou c moi comme
pour lesul jeis
ch je ne suis pas choqué il s'agit
encore une fois de TR ou quatre
personnes je pense qu'il faut se calmer
un
peu je te dis je te dis que je P
question plein de thèmes sur lesquels je
suis désolé je me suis retrouvé tout
seul donc c'est pas une question de
courage ne nous fait pas ce procès là
moi
jeèou demain ce sera peut-être des
catholiques ou des bouddhistes je m'en
fous je considère qu'il y a d'autres
combat à mener aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
ça ne me choque pas au sens où c'est la
question qui est posée ça ne me choque
pas en revanche oui je suis d'accord la
religion c'est quelque chose d'intime
qui s'exerce chez soi mais calmons-nous
un peu
quoi répondre à très gentiment Raym dit
vous n'avez pas la même position ici que
dehors excuse-moi Raym j'ai la même
position partout j'ai jamais changé et
d'autre part et d'autre part exp
explique que là il y en a il y a 5
personnes qui prient 30 et si c'était
300 et ben moi je vous le dis si c'est
300 c'est tout aussi formidable le
nombre n'a rien à voir
làdans attendez c'est encore pire parce
que mais laissez-moi finir là vous dites
c'est pas gênant parce qu'ils sont dans
leur coin
il mais laissez-moi finir ma phrase ou
c'est pas gênant parce que ils sont 30
quand c'était les musulmans mais si ils
sont 300 quel est le problème 300
personnes qui pr em tu fais tu fais
savoir tu fais pas savoir de de pas
comprendre pourquoi on dit que c'est pas
pareil si je passe dans la rue qu' a un
mec en train de pisser ça me gêne pas si
y en a 2000 en train de pisser pour moi
ça me gne pas
[Applaudissements]
pareil so les musulmans ou les Juifs
c'est exactement ce que je vous ai
expliqué avanier ou hier et ce soir VI
dire ça me dérange pas je m'en fous le
jour o on a 3 non ça dérange
pasenezéroportmentire c'est pour ça que
votre nom est intenable en fait pouro 30
c'estible
ose donc c'est pour ça que Point Bar on
ne fait pas ça dans un lieu public comme
ça c'est très clair c'est très pour tout
le monde pour toutes les religions on n
parle plus et voilà il y a pas de
problème comme dans la justice il y a
une question de proportionnalité et il y
a une question aussi voilà sil y a deux
personnes qui sont assis sur un coin et
qui sont en train de prier ça Gera
personne personne le verra à partir du
moment où il y en a 50 100 150 oui c'est
autre
chose
oh c'est insupportable he je dis
insupportable non non mais je vous le
dis si c'est vous insupportable Valé t
comme il y a la loi et l'esprit de la
loi et ben là effectivement soyons
pragmatiques on est dans des dans une
situation actuellement où déjà la France
elle est fracturée où il y a des tension
évitons de mettre de l'huile sur le feu
ça là pour l'instant il y a dans cette
image là et dans la dans la précédente
qu'on nous avait montré des pèlerins qui
allaient à la mec il n'y avait aucune
aucun aucun trouble à l'ordre public à
partir du moment où il y a aucun trouble
à l'ordre public ne rajout-on pas de lu
sur
juopoup trouble à l'ordre public ma
position sera
différenteurait
dérangé sur cette image il ne gne
personne mais non je te pose une
question sans musul qui pr est- Dér mais
tu me fais de la politique fiction je te
demande si cette image te choque est-ce
qu' a du monde autour elle choque pas
c choque pas qui pr juif pr est-ce que
ça te choque
ouép de
pour c'est un aéroport c'est pas une
mosqu ch ce soit une
priè
mais c'est la question c'est le fond
pourquoi ça te choque qu'il ait des
musulmans ou des Juifs qui prient par
aura beaucoup de monde qui vont prier ça
va peut-être gêner le fonctionnement pas
comme s'il faisait un match de foot là
on parle d'une prière c'est le fond
religion all fond du sujet all au fond
du sujet viment on parle pas de
personnes qui font une activité on parle
pas de personnes qui jou qui F tennis
qui
ch choc dans le fond qu'il y a un
certain nombre de personnes pourquoi pas
100 qui fassent une prière juif musulman
que la foi la spiritualité
VO pasî s'il vous plaît jacard avait une
question pour Ron Raymon imagine tu es
maère d'une commune il y a qure ou CIN
personnes devant une mosquée qui prie
dehors c'est pas tellement un trouble à
l'ordre publicque a TR ou quatre
personnes en revanche il y en a 500 qui
prie parce que la population a augmenté
est-ce que là tu vas pas prendre des
décisions pour qu'il puisse prier tu vas
rien fairered tu sais ce que je fais le
vendredi pass argent vendred je va te
répondre arg vendredi le vendredi les
rues elles sont barré avec la mosqu tu
es obligé de faire des détours il y a
des bouchons le à jeun villiier la
mosquée de jeunevilier c'est pareil le
vendredi tu peux pas te garer nulle part
parce que les places de parking il y en
a plus nulle part les rues quand tu sors
à 14h tu es dans les bouchons pendant 20
30 minutes tu es dans les bouchons ça ne
me dérange pas tolérance ils sortent
d'un lieu de culte ça ne me dérange pas
ils sortent de leur mosqué pas pris un
jour un jour tu as pas pris une amende
j'ai pris une amende parce que je sais
ouais là tu te fous de ma gueule non
mais vous me faites passer pour un
fachot vous me faites passer pour un S
faes passer pour le mec qui est
contreigion je suis peut-être pas le
plus tolérant j'ai pas cette prétenion
je suis tolérant avec les religions
quand je vais au Maroc je suis tolérant
quand je suis avec cy on fait Chabbat je
suis tolérant je mets laip je va
[Rires]
pas minutes de
prire moi jeis pas je dis pas ça Dér pas
dérange viment pas de procès je te fais
aucun procès je dis juste qu'il y a une
différence entre TR personnes qui
que qui voudexpr s'il vous plaît
jeis blessé moi par ce que
j'entends on est enain d'établir des
jauges rendez compte mot j'ai entendu le
mot des
jauges
rendez compte de ce que vous dit vous
êtes en train de dire et votre discours
il va vous mener où il va vous mener où
bon alors s'il y a 300 musulmans quelque
part là c'est trop a un trouble au juifs
il a un trouble à l'ordre publique et
Cera vous êtes
malad am vire ensemble que quand on vit
dans une communauté o Chun faut quand on
vit dans une communauté où chacun des
idées différentes on essaie que chacun
que ses idées ne soi pas gênantes pour
les autres donc TR oui 300 évidment
pourquoi tuappelles sa joue mais parce
que ça peut gêner les autres ça gne les
autres il faut réglementer qui et ben
comment mais ça
calme et ben ça gne ceux qui ne sont pas
de la même confession et qui du coup
vont être gênés ou ceux qui sont qui
mais j'ai pas les noms cétait con quoi
voilà c'est ça votre
problème impr précis qui personne qui
qui tu par tu parles tu parles duours
des confessions il y a plein de gens qui
sont
qui c'est dingue c'est abrait votre truc
en fait
[Applaudissements]
les par exemple les ils ont pas envieêre
gên dans le environnement comme ça
chacun do bon sens pourquoi tu parles de
jauge c'est n'importe
quoi c'est le problème que veux qu'il
dis-ce que tu veux qu'
dis
poloain va faire t numéro tu sens bien
que là je v avoir un argument donc tu tu
à nouveau tu nous fais ton numéro de
plaquette pourquoi je parlais de
proportionnalité tout à l'heure parce
que ce sont des cas qui sont déjà
présentés lorsque tu as 400 personnes
qui se vont devant un bâtiment et que il
y a il y a pas assez de monde le maire
prend une décision et il va
éventuellement faire faire construire
une mosquée bah oui mais ce sont des cas
ce sont des cas concret dont je te parle
donc c'est pas oui la question de la
proportionnalité c'est une question et
tu vas avoir des gens autour autour du
quartier qui vont se plaindre qui vont
écrire au
dir la réalité voil g c'est les mariages
quand il y a des mariages tout le monde
est d'accord pour que dehors on jette
des graineries on chante on célèbre les
mariés quand il y a des rodéos que ça
bouche les res les rues qu' a des roues
arrière c'est un bordel total et ben non
là on règlemente son de bon sens le Réo
ou à c'est interdit par la loi monsieur
c'est pas on peut jeter du riz
sortie ben oui mais t'explique justement
je t'explique justement que les
débordement c'est les rodéos et quand
c'est quand c'est limité comme ça tout
le monde accepte et tout le monde
comprende juste est-ce que tu as une
question à
poser en fait c'est ça le problème on va
tiens on va voir ce qu'en pense les
téléspectateurs ti oui 79% non 20 %
c'est pareil no téléspectateur voilà il
sont